[Applause]
first we have a little time and i was
excited to do something we're going to
call
instead of q and a druinette
because we love to pun my name with
everything and it turns out it kind of
weirdly does
um like you've got mail drew's got mail
it just it's one of those
words that works um and i love answering
questions i
would love to live a life where i'm of
any assistance to anyone i think that's
part of what i'm here on the planet to
do i don't care if it's
i mean medical is probably not my field
you don't want to ask me about medical
but
design or food or friendship anything
i love to discuss things with people
by the way dr drew little animals i see
a lot of animals in the wall
okay so i would love to answer any
questions and i think we have one from
marcus
marcus hi how are you hi marcus
how are you i'm good i'm doing a lot of
online dating and the women i've been
beating
i like always insist on paying for the
date i feel kind of bad because
i'm old-fashioned shouldn't i be paying
do we split it
what do i do um okay i am with you
i like old-fashioned chivalry
that said i'm an equal opportunity woman
who does
love to treat someone else as well so
and we're in a very modern age right now
so sometimes i think women take it as
like an empowerment thing
and so i don't want to impede on that
but i'm with you marcus it's nice to be
a gentleman and you know
as much as our world is modern i miss
the old-fashioned ways so
what about this what if you say you know
what
i'm actually going to pay for dinner but
if you'd like to buy something else
like how about that like oh that's great
yeah
allow me to do this and you get the next
one or you can surprise me with
something
but it makes me feel good to do this you
know
for you i love that thank you so much
i'm on
i'm gonna use that next time it might be
just delaying and procrastinating the
inevitable
but at least you've sort of you know
done what feels right in your heart and
then enabled them
to get creative right right
it's like two birds in one stone it's
lazy inevitable but then like it opens
up a little bit of creativity
yeah yeah you can i welcome you to pay
for the next thing or surprise me with
something
but i have to say i wish there were more
gentlemen like
you out there in the world marcus and um
i will say on behalf of one
female thank you it's nice to be treated
like a lady
well say you thank you
thank you you have a good one you too
okay oh i love marcus
next up newly engaged couple anna marie
and michael
hi guys congratulations
thank you so much i would love
to see if i can help in any way or be of
some assistance what is your question
so we uh just got engaged and we're in
the middle of planning our registry
and we were wondering what are some
items that we definitely should not add
to the registry
um huh that's a very good question
what is it that you love what is it that
you would like because sometimes i feel
like
it's okay to be a little unorthodox like
if you're a collector of something
maybe it can be all about that one thing
what do you guys like
well we love to cook we're really big
and we love working together in the
kitchen so
we have mostly been putting kitchen
stuff on but i don't know
like we also really like
we actually met at a brewery so we also
like
stuff with beer and just stuff for our
home
definitely we also have a little corgi
mix so we love him
because we have the same legs and
they're the queen's dogs and they're
just the cutest they're the cute and
their butts are so fluffy i just want to
like grab it and pull kind of like a
lamb like
i'm gonna get in that wall you know what
i say
get in the driver's seat put on there
you can buy
us like craft beers and put a little
label on it
so that when we pull it out to drink it
we know that you've
come into our evening and you know or
day and like this is make it
sell it as a memory because people
probably are like i don't want to just
get them beer
but that's your thing so tell people
what you want register i love food
52 and i'll see maybe see if they have a
wedding
wedding registry but literally do you
be you you don't need candlesticks and
all that shimata that's just gonna go in
a closet anyway you're gonna have to
repurpose and feel guilty
be you get a registry for craft beers
and say turn us on to things we don't
know about yet in the craft beer
world and like make it a scavenger hunt
for them to empower you
i love that i love that yeah it
cause we all know where that other stuff
is going and
um so i say do exactly what you would
want to keep and also i think like
selling it like when we enjoy this like
you know you could maybe make labels and
have them fill out like a digital label
to you guys from x and then when you
bring it out
you can say cheers to them oh that's a
really cool idea
yeah i mean it's just a good you know
it's like more a manipulative way to
just get good booze and make it like see
sell it as like a poetic gesture right
well cheers to you both thank you anna
marie and michael
it's my pleasure
this is so fun i really i just i could i
could
live doing nothing but this all right we
have time for one more to shayna
yes perfect how are you drew hi
i'm so good thank you for asking me a
question
i don't even know what it is but i'm
really excited
so my question is i'm a businesswoman
just like you
in design my background is interior
design and in the height of the pandemic
i ended up launching an event company
and i want to know if
i should divulge all my time to my
business which has been doing really
well
despite the pandemic and we have really
good projected numbers or
should i still keep my nine to five
i think keep your nine to five um
right now because everything is so
uncertain
economically especially during the
pandemic
and sometimes i think i have to say
it's the truth and it sucks but it is
true
it takes so much work and effort
to have a business it's just nights and
days and weekends
so i would say stick with your job until
you feel like you're in a financial
place
where you can let go because i do worry
if you want to get back to it
the job marketplace is so difficult
right now because of everything that's
going on
and that security does not feel good to
give up
but if you work extra hard at nights
and weekends then you can get your
business to a place
where then you can leave your job where
it's a choice and not a scary like
ultimatum either or wait until you're
empowered financially
but don't stop working on your business
and if you figured out
a way to make event planning successful
this year then you're amazing at it
thank you i appreciate that i would
assume that would be the most difficult
business right now
so you're on to something stick with it
and just hopefully maybe in a few months
or a year which goes by in the blink of
an eye
you can comfortably transition okay
i hope that's good advice and by the way
most
importantly give do and believe
everything you can to your business and
all of that hard work
will pay off it'll be exhausting you'll
be working double hard
but i know that it will pay off
in the end okay thank you so much
and get financially comfortable because
life is short and you have to live your
dream
and you have to make it happen in a safe
and sort of responsible way but
again if you figured out how to make
that occupation work right now
then you have got the goods
thank you thank you to shayna thank you
anna marie and michael
and marcus thank you so much so
if you're at home you can go to our
website and find out how you
too can join our vffs i mean
i'm dying to hang out
you